[Music]
happy infinity war day we've waited so
long for this movie and the day is
finally here I'm going right to the
theater after I finish this video I'm
gonna wait in line for hours I don't
care I'm so excited
the last few days have been hard I've
stayed off social media and I've avoided
all new trailers and new breakdown
videos because I want to go in with just
little amount of spoilers as I can so
I'm so excited only a handful of hours
more to go I'm freaking out so with it
coming out in just a few hours here is
the Avengers infinity war prelude part 2
before we get started don't forget to
enter our giveaway for a chance to win a
full surround sound speaker system all
you have to do is be subscribed to my
channel subscribe to the stupendous wave
like and comment below your favorite
superhero that could be Marvel DC or
anything else also don't forget to tweet
me or DM me on Twitter pictures of
yourself at the premiere you might make
it into a video Infinity Ward Prelude
part 2 takes place in New York at the
sanctum sanctorum with Doctor Strange
and Wong dr. strange awakes from
meditation in which Wong is waiting
Foreman says that they need to talk one
begins to say that it's interesting to
note how far Doctor Strange has come
since they've met mastering the mystic
arts and just in time to defeat case
Ilyas and Dormammu as in shows Doctor
Strange Mordo and Wong talking after the
fight
Mordo saying that they violated the
natural law of the universe and that
there will be a reckoning then it cuts
back to present time where Wong states
that there's clearly a mystical balance
that must be maintained and the eye of
agamotto is once at facet of the cosmic
balance but there are five more he of
course is referring to the Infinity
stones and Doctor Strange Aswang to
enlighten him Wong states that him and
Doctor Strange wield the time stone in
order to protect their dimension but
there are those who seek the stones out
purely in pursuit of their own lust for
power this next part is really cool
because Wong goes on to tell the story
of
hon Schmidt or otherwise known as red
school and how he obtained the tesseract
or the space stone it goes to the past
of March 1942 in tongues burg Norway
it's just red skull and some troops that
he has with him go into a building in
which they come across a man here's
where it gets really interesting because
the man says what you seek is just a
legend and which rescuer applies then
why make such an effort to conceal it
the tesseract was a jewel of Odin's
treasure room it is not something one
buries but I think it is close yes it's
very interesting that on earth of March
1942 they're talking about as guards
King Odin which really makes me wonder
who this man exactly is my guess is that
he's an Asgardian that was sent to earth
for some purpose
Red Skull then turns his head and says
egg drizzle it then shows him in front
of a wall that has a tree carved into it
with some Asgardian markings surrounding
it in which he says tree of the world
guardian of wisdom another interesting
thing that I noticed is I looked up the
definition of egg drizzle and which it
says a huge ash tree located at the
center of the earth with three routes
one extending to nil time the underworld
one to John Heim land of the Giants and
one to Asgard
Land of the Gods clearly this has some
link to Asgard maybe Odin visited earth
and put this here himself Red Skull
pushes a secret button in which Shore
pops out and he finds the tesseract he
thing goes on to say how Red Skull built
his army with a tesseract and then how
Captain America defeated him and how
Howard Stark eventually found the
tesseract he thing goes on to talk about
the Battle of New York which was the
first Avengers movie and how it was the
result of the mind stone arriving and
luckily the Avengers were there to
defeat them and Thor took the tesseract
back to Asgard he then says
unfortunately Thor returned a short time
later in another earthbound battle over
the Infinity stones then he proceeded to
talk about Malekith and how he will did
the reality stone or known as the ether
he states that Thor defeated him and
then it shows lady SIF giving the
reality stone to the collector for
safekeeping
Doctor Strange then jokes about the
Asgardians tending to bring their fair
share of trouble when involved with
these stones and which Wong replies you
have no idea
Vinh tells the story about the mine
stone and we flash back a few years back
to sokovia even starts to talk about
what happened in the movie The Avengers
age of Ultron he says how the Hydra
scientists explored the stones
applications on human tissue which
resulted in the enhanced telepathic
abilities of one a maximov and the
superhuman speed of her brother Petro
it's just one of Maxima or the Scarlet
Witch manipulating Tony's mind giving
him a vision of everybody that he knows
in the avengers dine plus an alien
attack on earth and from there Tony got
it into his head that he needed to
protect the world at any cost he then
talks about how Tony Stark and Bruce
Banner created Ultron with the intent of
him being Earth's protector but of
course it blew up in his face he says
that Ultron sought to create a new host
form for his true consciousness the mine
stone but the Avengers intervene and
instead transformed it into a vision of
hope and with visions help The Avengers
were able to defeat Ultron one goes on
to talk about the Power Stone in which
we relive scenes from the guardians of
the galaxy wong states that it remains
hidden across the stars protected by a
massive ocean but the particular stone
is often coveted for its destructive
potential
but wong says that their tasks as
masters of the mystic arts is of a
particular singular focus to protect
this world or the world that they're
living on which is earth and that if
someone else should encounter threat of
the Power Stone
they'll have to pray for someone capable
of ensuring their own salvation in which
it shows the guardians of the galaxy
defeating Ronan Strange is about to ask
about the sixth Infinity stone but Wong
stops him this part is really cool
because it shows us what happened right
before Thor and Loki arrived in the
sanctum sanctorum and thor ragnarok then
shows a scene of dr. strange taking loki
and leaving a card for thor to go to the
sanctum sanctorum we then go to the
scene from thor ragnarok where dr.
strange asks thor while he's there and
why he brought loki dr. strange says
that he'll help thor and since thor and
loki on their way to see odin then
Doctor Strange returns to Wang to learn
more about the sixth Infinity stone
walling pulls out some books and some
papers and says little is known about
the sixth and final stone the soul stone
it's interesting to note that they show
a page in one of the books that long is
looking at and it shows some planets
there's some theories going around that
the soul stone is actually a planet and
that we see the planet and some
the trailers that have been released
it's just an interesting thing to note
I'm not gonna mention it anymore because
I see the movie in like four hours but
Wang goes on to say that if what little
they do know about it turns out to be
true it could prove to be the biggest
threat of them all and I love how it
ends it's super dramatic and epic and
sets it up for Avengers infinity war
Doctor Strange says okay so end of the
day as long as no one finds all these
stones and puts them together we're in
the clear and which Wang replies correct
but if someone does attempt to do so we
will need to prepare for the greatest
battle the universe has ever seen and it
shows a picture of Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet so that's it for
Avengers infinity war Prelude part 2 I
hope you enjoyed it and I hope it makes
you super pumped to see Avengers
infinity war tonight let me know in the
comments below when you're seeing and
finding you are and what you're most
excited to see in the movie also again
don't forget to enter our speaker
giveaway all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous waves channel leave a like
and drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero from Marvel DC or
otherwise I'm gonna do a video after the
movie with my reactions and thoughts and
if you guys see it tonight please come
back and tell me what you guys thought
thank you so much for watching I hope
everyone loves the movie tonight woof
woof
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more
[Music]